Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
below me Galloway
5:1
my
[Applause]
[Music]
looma as a victory that's not even what
if you good with pistons you I'm gonna
I'm that guy with a piece yeah getting
up closer closely to no one
okay one of you come one let's go this
she weapons wanted you
shut it down
you call me shaking like beer cuts we
don't want more game or what let's
switch it up yet
Josie boys against boys yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
yeah now me no ma'am
it's actually so Matt look
I'm loving it I'm loving it
bah-bah I hate soda watch your back
watch your back
check the shoulder - shoulder no look
how long it takes me
ah goldway for going keep going keep
going keep going
go keep going just keep pushing keep
pushing trust me no pistol she's got me
there for real for real are we doing no
longer slapped I know who was sit down
ah
whoa Kobe does the truth
42 to blame how you did
oh okay well play I'm getting my energy
back you getting it back straight day
you see three seconds to month I'll be
one down let's go let's go that's way
too choosy poison
[Music]